un día después del trágico festival de
astro world en houston llega la hora del
balance ocho víctimas tenían entre los
14 y los 27 años y 13 personas siguen
hospitalizadas
las autoridades locales revelaron
también que hubo varias sobredosis de
opioides en el concierto
las familias de los fallecidos y todos
los afectados merecen respuestas sobre
lo que ocurrió anoche
y por eso pide una investigación
objetiva e independiente sobre lo que
pasó y cómo podría haberse evitado
el viernes el concierto del rapero
travis cote estaba agotado y a las nueve
de la noche cuando empezó la actuación
la multitud se abalanzó repentinamente
hacia el escenario un momento caótico
donde los seguidores atestiguan que no
podían respirar ni mover los brazos
[Música]
la seguridad del personal de emergencias
no podía llegar físicamente a ninguna
persona de la multitud había demasiada
gente y en algún momento las barricadas
se convirtieron en un obstáculo como si
alguien no pudiera llegar hasta allí la
gente estaba como atrapada en la zona el
cantante por su parte expresó su
conmoción estoy absolutamente devastado
por lo que ocurrió anoche me comprometo
a trabajar junto con la comunidad de
houston para sanar y apoyar a las
familias que lo necesitan los
investigadores ya empezaron a examinar
el lugar y los numerosos vídeos para
entender lo que llevó a uno de los
conciertos más mortíferos de la historia
de eeuu